à quai les touristes se pressent pour
avoir la meilleure place
la croisière du jour et complète sans
passager à bord savez-vous qui sait qu'à
dessiner cas vente et les églises telle
que vous la voyez aujourd'hui à monsieur
qui était très connu léonard de vinci
au programme balades nature sur les
canaux et découvert des excuses
celle ci est l'une des plus vieilles au
monde elle date de 1604 jamais vu c'est
aussi voir de plus près les ouvrages
phares de la ville le pont canal à
briare le tourisme fluvial fonctionne
bien
les prestataires ont trouvé leur vitesse
de croisière une manne financière pour
les commerces sans les bateaux avrillas
la ville de vivre et mal on va dire ça à
dire quand même but du bio n'ont fait
quarante mille clients et sur le pont
canal le bogolan attire quand même trois
mille trois cent cinquante mille
personnes à l'année oui c'est qu'un
potentiel comme un canal plus loin ces
vacanciers ont opté pour une formule
plus intimiste nous croisière à bord
d'un bateau avec une roue à aubes le
bateau différent aussi donc c'est pour
ça on à la flash et un peu sur le style
du bateau aussi
c'est pour ça g borne et juste entre
nous un petit en famille loin de la
foule à la découverte de l'ancien canal
commandé par henri iv
il était vraiment essentiel au niveau de
la loire parce que la loire été beaucoup
utilisé par les bateliers beaucoup moins
maintenant et y lutter utilisé
essentiellement pour le pro merci au
21ème siècle la seule marchandise encore
transporté sur les cadeaux de briare
c'est le touriste un commerce toujours
florissant